well
hello how am i leaving jaramillo with
the briefing for today tuesday
march 2 more people are eligible to
receive the virus vaccine in
clark county groups that
are under community support and in
supply chains are now
eligible  this includes
public transportation workers communicators
walking employees and
airport operators among others for a
complete list visit our online page
or diagonal dotcom in Spanish
this week in the city of north las
vegas organizes two clinics to give the
crib against the coronavirus  -today and
tomorrow- people over 65 years old
will be able to get vaccinated at the school that is
in sprints there is near alexander and
pedestrian on friday the vaccines will be
available at the recreation center
located near homs and by streep
you can make an appointment by visiting the
page of  jacques at vi dot com or by
calling 702 3 42 84 17
meanwhile the almu will continue to be given
free meals for
clark county students for the remainder of the
school year those following the
virtual learning model
can also pick up their meal at any
local middle and high school
to find out the
nearest delivery site visit and if it's from
nutri is live.com and now we turn to
the weather forecast a nice sunny day is expected
with temperatures a
little above normal the maximum
will be close to 69 degrees and the
minimum 45 degrees for tomorrow clouds wind and
chance of rain that  have a
nice day I am this light you hear me
after your brief
inclusion informative in Spanish